la bombe de peinture et un mur dans un
lieu abandonné api grave depuis près de
15 ans le mur un terrain de jeu pour ce
jeune niggli noir n'est vraiment pas le
truc ici à plein de plein de black book
machine j'ai retrouvé tout à l'heure en
fait se sceller des choses que j'ai
retrouvée qui sont les laits je crois
que c'est mon tout premier ce qu'on
appelle un black book en fait c'est un
drap bouquin auquel on faisait des
lettrages tout commence ici à benne dans
la maison familiale
le street art tapis pierre antoine
ménard de son vrai nom le découvre par
son grand frère et la révélation un mur
et une photo en souvenir une passion qui
le fait ensuite travaillé en atelier
quand est revenue de bienvenue dans un
grand voyage il est parti sur barcelone
je crois dans les années 2000 quelque
chose comme ça et en fait il a monté une
boutique de ce prêt et moi je suis allé
lui rendre visite en vacances je devais
avoir 15 16 ans et j'ai découvert à
barcelone toute une équipe qui est
devenu mon collectif plus tard après je
suis revenu ici en banlieue parisienne
et après plus tard sur paris et là j'ai
découvert le graffiti le vrai graffitis
les tunnels du métro tout ça va et après
après ses noces est un peu c'est un peu
comme une drogue
quand on est piqué ben devient un lieu
de stockage 15 ans de travail et plus
d'une centaine d'oeuvres réalisées
aujourd'hui ils créent ils recherchent
ils dessinent à bobigny mêlant culture
des années 80 références classiques la
bombe
mais plus on c'est l'outil je sais d'une
consistance de deux murs avaient toile
touchera avec de l'acrylique de la
peinture de chantiers beaucoup de
beaucoup de 2,2 technique populaire en
fait j'utilise un produit qu un espèce
de latex aussi pour superposer des
couches de couleurs et venir gratter que
les couches d'eau soit par s ce prêt de
la pastel grâce beaucoup d'encre ouais
un peu un peu tout ce que je trouve
longtemps considérées comme marginales
dégradants et illégale
le street art investit aujourd'hui les
galeries api vit de son art vente de
toiles et expositions comme ici à la
celle saint cloud avec le collectif 1980
là l'intelligence en fait avec finesse
d'amener l'histoire de l'art dans le
street art dont qui rattache un peu les
choses dans le collectif il ya plusieurs
artistes qui ont fait les beaux-arts lui
n'a pas fait les beaux-arts mais là ils
puissent vraiment son énergie là donnant
même s'il explose api n'a pas abandonné
le graffiti et la rue alors ouvrez bien
les yeux pour découvrir les trois
lettres de sa signature
[Musique]